okay so you are now on the very short
list for vice-president should Joe Biden
choose you and I love your answer
because usually people play games with
this and your answer is yeah it's fast
I'll take it so let me ask you this
thing about Joe Biden what would be your
advice to black lives matter about what
they go after him for because they were
pretty tough on Hillary last time when
she surely would have been the better
candidate on issues that are important
to them and Joe's you know a lot of
people talking about busing in the 70s
and the 94 Crime Act crime bill which he
supported what would be your advice well
first of all my advice is to understand
that this is 2020
and we have an enormous range of
challenges on our plate that deeply
affect the lives and the well-being of
African Americans in this country
whether it's the Cova 19 pandemic the
economic recession almost depression and
now what we are seeing with respect to
perpetual police violence and many of
the underlying manifestations of what
remains systemic racism and we have a
choice either Donald Trump remains in
office who has governed in a blatantly
racism racist and divisive way with
utter disregard for the concerns of many
Americans including African Americans or
we elect Joe Biden somebody whose heart
and soul understand that our country is
stronger when we're united who when who
understands that the African American
population is an integral and equal part
of this country and they have been they
have suffered enormously over
generations and that it's time to invest
in health in education in housing and in
the environment and so many of the
underlying conditions which have
exacerbated the systemic racism in this
country and also obviously to deal
squarely with the challenges that we've
seen on our streets with respect to the
police and criminal justice system and
so you know I
understand that there are those
protesting who may wish for a more
radical agenda but I think in Joe Biden
what we stand to get is somebody who
understands and appreciates the
challenges is willing to invest real
resources and real energy in them and it
comes from a position of of true passion
I worked with Joe Biden bill very
closely for eight years I know him in
fact I worked with him before the Obama
administration when he was in the Senate
and I was at the State Department
there's nobody that brings to this
challenge a greater sense of the
humanity that we all share and a
commitment to make that manifest in
reality and in policy not just in
rhetoric so I would urge those that are
questioning how they might vote in this
context to be very mindful of what the
choice is it couldn't be more stark okay
now where you're sitting right now is a
place where there is taxation but not
representation and I learned a lot about
DC recently when President Trump called
out the troops there you know because
they don't have representation so
whereas other states have governors who
make certain decisions I guess in the in
that district it's up to the president
statehood I know for DC is something
very important to you is it not it is
I'm born and raised Washingtonian and
I've lived all my life or most of my
life in a place where like every other
one of the more than 700,000 citizens of
the District of Columbia we are by the
way a population larger than to other
states Wyoming and Vermont and
comparable to Alaska and Delaware we pay
more per capita in taxes than any state
in the Union and more in federal taxes
in the aggregate than 22 other states
and yet we have no voting representation
in either the house or the Senate and
that is taxation without representation
but it's worse than that because we
don't have any measure of sovereignty
equivalent to a state Donald Trump can
treat us as a playground as he did when
he called out federalized military
forces to
ployed violence against largely peaceful
protesters this has got to change is
long overdue it's a remnant of racism
and political expedience because
Republicans understand that by virtue of
the fact that the District of Columbia
is almost now still majority black and
very democratic that they don't want any
additional voting representation out of
us but that's completely undemocratic
and it's one more reason why we need a
democratic house a Democratic Senate and
a Democratic president in the White
House because that is what it will take
to change we can fix this great iniquity
through legislation that's signed into
law by the president
you